[Music]
what's up GQ I'm Diplo and these are my
essentials first up cowboy
muscle where that is my essential always
bring a nice cowboy hat it's actually
difficult to travel with one you got to
bring a cowboy hat I'm one of my ears
really sit on my head right now but you
have to bring a hat box so it's like a
circle
come on your flight and the overhead
compartment I just like them not like
the shape we had made a couple of
special outfits for different shows and
award ceremonies I'll probably keep
wearing them until I finish this Thomas
Wesley project but I think I'm addicted
to cowboy hats and boots and alcohol
it's become a thing always bringing
headphones on the road I'm not a big air
pod guy I'm addicted to noise canceling
headphones these bows really good at
kind of they're not that cool when you
have air pods that cool if you like rich
right these you got on your neck when
you put these on you literally can't
hear anything else music sounds so good
on these like a mix records in these I
can vibe out with them this is another
set of this is actually my friend
started a company called silent mode and
these you put on when you take on a
red-eye flight you could actually open
this up and move the speaker to fit your
head perfectly so it's same as a noise
cancelling pair of headphones but it's
got a total blackout mass that's
comfortable you can sleep with this you
know if you have your phone you have a
different apps where you can listen to
the relaxing sounds or even like you
know heavy metal if you want to
I always bring a book as a bookmark I
have my sons it so I can always keep him
close even though there's a bunch of
pictures on my phone too but I was
taught to read this book yet so kid type
is good or not but Willie Nelson super
cool I love books about musicians and
historical figures and I love
non-fiction books like the sapiens Home
Videos and Howard Zinn and maybe about
history culture never met Willie Nelson
I want to get him to send me a package
of his marijuana though Lily's reserve
it's pretty good stuff I her snip dog
says Willie Nelson's the only guy that
can out smoke him so that's kind of a
big accomplishment how's the hook shot
this is Opie one this is made by a
company called teenage engineering
actually comes with a case that's
similar to like the velcro of the
sleeping mask and this thing is so cool
it's very very sturdy it's got my name
on it because people trust steel from
Studio for a while they're really into
man you know they only made a couple
hundred of them and I got it really
early from the Swedish company makes
them you can literally do because
sequence on here you can I use a MIDI
keyboard ROM on the road
[Music]
you do so many things on this she has a
million presets you can always install
more sounds on it so it's always able to
upgrade when you look at the screen
it's really beautiful tools all the
different things that have like years
effects to go to the drum settings to
presets anyway it's hard to learn it's a
really big learning curve because it's a
different DW than anything else a we use
but you have to get a book and download
it and print it and taxing on how to use
it I will unlock like 10% of what this
does so if I had more time I'd love to
like learn this thing and just kill it
but for just making music sounds on the
road this is perfect this is all my
stuff
this is a dosis pen so this is a pen
that's a little more heavier on THC less
on CBD and you smoke this time to be
smoked one hit it buzzes it even buzzed
this time only get too high I got to do
this whole photo shoot so it buzzes next
one hit so you can kind of like
calculate how much you need to either
sleep or get worked on or no cuz if
you're just like rolling joints all the
time you don't really know what you know
how much you're smoking or what you're
doing this is also good to sleep this is
a company called ki cocoa
they make it tea that's a CBDT that
really like knocks you I don't feel high
from it I drink that when I'm on the
road and there's my vitamins I took
three day three packs take this this
times like three almost fifteen vitamins
a day and then I mix the lead to you
know to the kiss I'm on the road I want
to store it but I'll be legal across
borders with that but whenever I was
crazed I'm a rock star
face moisturizer all the Henrickson's a
great company to make a lot of different
things for face mask to serums to just
regular old moisturizer in the day so
sunscreen this was a good i do supply
got like although my face right now all
right
this is i'm looking like a pretty boring
dad right here like nothing exciting
i'll have that many changed but i keep
them with me a good cube legs have a
couple pair i think they're different
like layers on my neck
they look nice when you wear kind of
Wester shirts that are open and cowboy
hat something like rock and that stop a
little bit it looks nice
it's mice box from atlanta i wore some
stuff by the VMAs a multicolored rainbow
different gemstone cable makes chain
I'm not really a big jewelry person but
I like like Cuban links um I think that
gets there yeah I have a couple of
watches black said never wear
I think watches are actually good
investments Jane's not so much it's hard
to resell it but watch this middle high
some out get reselling for more if you
got like a nice thick or Rolex well I'm
like the dad am like time to tell you
like can buy a watch as an investment
not like just to show off to your
friends though alright what else is
exciting over there you know what bring
over the wisps these are great I let's
say right now I don't like the fact that
they're single-use plastic you gotta
brush your teeth as much as possible
guys three times a day all right if you
don't brush your teeth every day I'm
gonna find out where you live I'm gonna
beat your ass I'm telling you right now
brush your teeth if you can't go to the
gas station by these cuz they're little
tooth brushes that you use once the
problem with these is that you start
getting too comfortable using them and
you like walking around using them like
in public and it's kind of disgusting
I'm kind of
I do that sometimes it's a little bit of
toothpaste I think in the gel here and
it just kind of breaks in when you when
it's wet when your saliva and then you
can floss with this side rush or this
side breath smells great dr. girls you
don't have like piece of spaghetti your
new teeth this is a girl munities she
taught me how to meditate so when I hold
these in two different hands you kind of
do your matches and I listen to her
voice and she speaks we do it a little
six seven minute kind of coaching my
meditation so I'll do it enough I wish
you'd do more meditation but I'll chime
the line a lot of my friends are
producers of musicians I'll bet it's a
like Mark Ronson's a really big into
Transcendental Meditation so I wish I
could do more of it and I think that it
helps you if your life is chaotic to
kind of ground yourself and give you
guys some more time that you need people
told me actually Kutcher told me once
that he meditates for 20 minutes and it
says to give them two more extra hours
of sleep every night but he doesn't get
I got tells me weird stuff that when I
stand that guy's like insane whatever he
does he's doing the right thing because
he's he's a boss this was from BMW so I
don't show for them again I got this ask
for a car back they don't really drink
coffee that much and a thermos I kind of
drink in paper cups or when they get
home this is nice to have you always
have to have a water bottle with you see
don't use plastic water bottles if you
can afford it and this is full water too
and you can take it around it's so much
better and you go to get refillable
water everywhere you go and saves you a
little money but also save our planet
another thing on the road this is gonna
like put it all together how much for
dad I am this is a chess set you brown I
play with my friends that do know how to
play not many are like in the chessick I
am my son plays chess to me a lot so
it's nice to him
it's a great thing to have on the road I
don't have any video games like video
game guy and I think every time you play
chest you get better at your minds
probably get sharper I suggested you
guys have for one my new hobby chests
I've been doing it for like 40 years
swear to God I just keeps it more fun
every time stuff little on the road
chess set actually I always keep a pair
of shorts in my bag because when I'm on
the road I don't waste any time I want
to go straight when I get to that
Airport straight in a car on the way for
my luggage I let someone else take it I
go straight to hotel and go to the gym
right when I land or go into a pool if
they have one hopefully they have one
it's nice to have that to kind of like
fix whatever jet like I might have and
just to feel some energy but I love to
run and I write bikes in the gym I
normally write bikes at home I don't
really bikes I live in Hollywood Hills
so it's really hard to get the bike up
and up and down
Sarah bikes a lot Eric does did people
actually bike two miles I don't how they
do it yeah whatever this is a macho bar
drink it's nice it's like caffeine I
don't really like to drink too much
caffeine it doesn't really work for me
makes you to direct a canter yo Red Bull
but this is really good it's not as
strong but it still gives you the energy
you need and it's healthier this is like
condensed matcha it's high-grade natural
caffeine and antioxidants so it's
healthy for you any green teas or matcha
teas are naturally antioxidants which is
good even coffees is not bad for you in
some ways if you drink coffee in
moderation it's got a lot of
antioxidants which helps you you know
live longer and stimulate your body in
different ways in your mind that's what
caffeine does it's all the rage right
now
matcha alright well that was it guys
thank you for checking out my essentials
I'm Diplo this is all my stuff called
leave all the cowboy house you can put
everything in there you just walk around
with that too
you